bonsoir michel fayyad merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france il ya eu encore des
commémorations ce soir devant le port de
beyrouth
deux mois après cette explosion une
enquête internationale et est toujours
exclu le président michel aoun n'en veut
pas oui il n'y a pas d'enquêté
internationale et je pense pas qu'il y
en aura parce que comme l'a dit votre
reportage en fait les différents partis
se tiennent
vous avez d'un côté la direction du port
qui depuis 92 est entre les mains du
parti d'hariri le ministère du transport
qui puis 92 et plus ou moins sur le
contrôle du parti de joe belote et la
contrebande dans le port qui est dans
les mains du mouvement amal du président
la grille du parlement nabih berry et du
hezbollah
donc chacun se tient et je pense que n'y
aura pas il y aura pas vraiment un
résultat de la moindre enquête
oui mais même cette soi-disant en quête
intérieure aboutira selon vous à zéro
responsabilité
oui il y aura peut-être quelques
personnes qui seront sacrifiés mêlée
mais les partis qui souhaitent qui ont
soutenu ces personnes ne seront pas
vraiment inquiéter tant qu'elle dirige
donc c'est parti dirige le pouvoir je
dirige le pays c'est ce qu'a finalement
cette explosion et cette enquête et à
l'image de ce que vit le pays
aujourd'hui c'est à dire une grave crise
politique justement à cause de la
corruption et à cause de cette classe
politique qui veut à tout prix se
maintenir au pouvoir
oui tout à fait en fait on a vu une
initiative qui a été faite par le
président français emmanuel macron et
qui en fait elle a été sabotée par
différentes choses la première étant que
le club des anciens premiers ministres
composé de quatre anciens communistes
qui a voulu nommer les ministres de
toutes les communautés
vous avez également le mouvement amal et
le hezbollah qui ont assisté à voir le
ministère des finances dans entre leurs
mains parce que c'est un ministère
incontournable dans le pays et vous avez
également donc le président le privé le
premier ministre désigné qui a voulu en
fait contourner les
les prérogatives prévues
constitutionnelle entre pour le
président la république
donc tout ça ça fait que l'initiative
française a été sabotée et par
essentiellement les partis sunnites et
les partis chiites c'est à dire les
partis qui sont représentés par le club
des anciens premiers ministres dont
carrie mikati et autres et les parties
civiles c'est-à-dire le mouvement amal
et le hezbollah
le principal défi aujourd'hui dit un
habile dérive le président du parlement
c'est de trouver le nom en tout cas de
trouver qui pour occuper ce poste de
premier ministre va qu'en maintenant
depuis plus d'une semaine
oui en fait le post communiste est
vacant depuis même plus longtemps que ça
depuis quasiment l'explosion pour ce que
le gouvernement diab a démissionné à ce
moment-là et l'expédié actuellement les
affaires courantes
il est effectivement très importante de
nommer un nouveau premier ministre et
qu'il formule un gouvernement le plus
rapidement possible parce que vous savez
aujourd'hui au liban
la banque centrale n'a plus de assez de
réserves en devises
les réserves en devises ne pourront
venir que disent que un mois un mois et
demi et vous savez avec ses réserves on
pouvait acheter du blé des médicaments
des produits pétroliers et après ça le
liban ne pourra plus le faire et déjà
vous avez une monnaie qui est
complètement par terre vous avez un
chômage au plus haut vous avez là une
chute du pouvoir d'achat des libanais
les des banques qui sont devenus des
banques zombies et du est en fait les
libanais ne peuvent plus utiliser leur
argent librement et les entreprises ne
peuvent plus ouvrir des lettres de
crédit pour faire leur travail
le pays est vraiment inter il faut
absolument un tout prix un gouvernement
le plus rapidement possible peu importe
qui serait promis mais un gouvernement
tout de suite pour pouvoir négocier avec
le fmi
et obtenir le déblocage des fonds à la
fois du fmi et la conférence aids qui
s'était tenue à paris en 2018
donc ça c'est le plus important
aujourd'hui on sait que la jeunesse
libanaise a beaucoup à nous tester avant
ces explosions
justement sur sur le pouvoir d'achat et
la catastrophe la crise économique dans
le pays et la corruption
où en sont ces manifestations
aujourd'hui on s'est beaucoup de jeunes
quittent le pays
oui beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui qui
quittent le pays parce que en fait les
ils sentent qu'il n'y a plus vraiment
d'espoir maintenant il est très
important de d'essayer de recréer cet
espoir et pour recréer cet espoir il
faut que justement l'argent
internationale viennent dans le pays
pour pouvoir relancer l'économie
aujourd'hui la jeunesse a quand même
porté au devant des idées importantes
par exemple elle a l'idée d'une certaine
laïcisation avec la demande de
d'unification du statut personnel dans
le code civil c'est-à-dire le mariage
civil entre autres c'est mais il ya
cette demande mais il ya également
d'autres il ya des réformes importantes
à faire par exemple la loi une loi sur
l'indépendance de la justice pour
pouvoir juger
justement les politiciens s'il le faut
et nous d'autant qu'il ya un outil de
juricomptables qui a été lancé il faut
également lancé les dossiers de
décentralisation qui sont prévues
constitutionnellement mais aussi le
dossier de la neutralité positive
permanente et reconnues
internationalement qui est porté
aujourd'hui par le patriarche maronite
il est très important d'avancer sur tous
ces dossiers pour pouvoir en fait donner
un nouveau souffle au liban un autre
dossier bien sûr c'est la
décentralisation parce que la
décentralisation fête permettra à ce que
des projets puissent se réaliser
localement que les citoyens puisse les
contrôler et donc en fait donner du sens
de l'économie libanaise
merci beaucoup michel lafaye hâte
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce soir
sur arte france